[Music]
what's up y'all sugar Ari Chambers here
from highlight her and we are live in
Texas to surprise the prez herself WNBA
Champion NECA agumake with a mural this
is her home court presented by Adele
let's go oh my God
how are you beautiful thank you for
having me in Texas you're here oh yeah
let's do a bigger and better
when I think of love and Trust I think
of community how important is it to
bring that Legacy back to Texas itself
oh I mean I think it's more important to
maintain it you know I think it's about
sustaining the Legacy me physically
leaving and achieving my dreams and my
goals does not mean that I've detached
myself from the history that I'm a part
of everywhere I go understanding that
I'm Houston I'm born in Tomball I'm
sci-fair that being a major part of my
identity and bringing that part of of me
to wherever I go to whatever I do is
kind of like an extension of my
community
I always try to tell Young aspirers when
you get to a new place don't try to be
someone else lean into what your
strengths are what got you there now to
stay there you're gonna have to be a
little bit more flexible a little bit
more open-minded about how you can now
navigate moving with the change coaching
beak certainly knows how to do that
because I'll walk into practice and
there's still things that they're doing
that I was doing now I won't say how
long ago that was
way back away
but then I see some new things too you
know and it's just lovely to see how she
can maintain that Legacy while also
still adapting to to the immediate needs
of those before one thing that I've
learned being raised nigerian-american
is that when you can Master a craft you
don't really see the Legacy and success
that you see unless you bring others
along to also maybe possibly master that
craft because it's also their passion
when you reach your destination who else
are you bringing along I'm definitely
the beneficiary of being able to
experience what it feels like for
someone to spend extra time talking to
me helping me train helping me watch
video helping me learn how to speak
publicly you know and and it's made so
much of my experience so much more
intentional but then it also allows me
to see how I can be like that for others
what do you hope to achieve going
forward I want to just leave a legacy of
contagion I want to leave people being
their greatest selves I want to step
outside of my boxes and my comfort zones
and continue to learn more about myself
both as a player and as a person and as
a woman in this world and I want to win
and you will I want to win and so let's
like take everything that your legacy
stands for give back to who made you
let's do it
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's gorgeous you did an amazing job I
just think it's really really dope Liz
you are the bright spot of this rainy
day because you captured Our Queen In
Living Color what went into every single
stroke it's a lot of love and just
trying to capture her Essence she's a
beautiful person in person and in the
painting I'm really honored seriously
this is beautiful I'm glad that I can
share it with my sci-fi you guys are
real ones for coming out here in this
weather
thank you so much for everything you do
it looks amazing it's beautiful thank
you so much and I think that we have
somebody else that's super special out
here amongst the family coach come on up
so coach I wouldn't be sharing this
moment with anyone else obviously I'm so
proud to have been a part of sci-fair
and for it to be symbolized and this
beautiful mural but there's another
surprise
um I'm here to tell you that Zell and
highlight her will be sending money
directly into your bank account with so
that's crazy thank you so much
thank you all uh highlight her Zell NECA
for choosing us it means a lot we're
family and it's we'll always be family
so thank you and Bobcat fight Never Dies
okay if I never died
[Applause]
the energy of the kids really really set
the vibe today despite the rain they
were the bright spot and another bright
spot was the beautiful mural being able
to see her reflected in this artwork was
really really pure and really really
special
so one more time give it up for the
president herself the WNBA Channel
[Applause]
I love it you're surrounded by so much
love how does it feel to just be back
with you your home team it feels amazing
you know Bobcat 5 Never Dies we all know
that that's true and I wouldn't be who I
am today without this program without my
coach and Rubik and I just wanted to
share this special moment and it's just
so wonderful to be back here to be
celebrated to be loved and to also love
and celebrate the people that really
raised me coach Ann come on up
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
we're here for you guys to celebrate
scifare the Legacy what it means to me
because you have an advocate you have a
leader you have a very strong individual
and woman who was a huge part of my life
[Applause]
that doesn't happen I'm generally
honestly I can't even believe that this
is happening you know we love you and we
tell the kids that every day and what
you've given to us your inspiration that
you've given to the kids each and every
day is is amazing not only to our kids
but the kids in this community kids
throughout the country and honestly kids
abroad so I can't again I am kind of
speechless so thank you very much I
can't believe it again
[Applause]
yeah highlighter always aims itself of
amplifying her highlighting women and
just allowing her to really shine in the
place she grew up
[Applause]
[Music]